[Music]
uh bart you used to be in the military
have you ever seen somebody get an
honorary ranking before
uh it's extremely rare
but i have met a few people
that have done it what's honorary
ranking so you know there's like ranks
like it goes like corporal sargent staff
stage or whatever
um
from each rank from one to another
there's like time there's requirements
you have to show leadership like you
have to it's like getting promoted in a
company
you have to
go through the steps and then
depending on how much you kill it it
might take longer or shorter and then so
the honorary ranking would be like
someone that just works at mcdonald's
from like day one and then maybe like in
six months they're the manager that you
promote straight to the matter past the
system manager passed shift manager
passed
lead teller so honorary kind of ranking
um when you hear that or when you see
somebody who is honorarily
titled that does that mean that they
like
more quickly bypass something or yeah
they yeah yeah endure do something
unique that like gave them that it's
probably they're outstanding
like oh that was a [ __ ] stud and then
usually when you see the the way they
carry themselves and the way they they
do their job you're like oh this guy's a
[ __ ] like he's like kobe he's like a
kobe like those fifth graders that we
saw in community college who wanted to
take college classes and i always
cracked me up because there was always
children in my classes can you drive on
base and [ __ ] as a as an honorary
rank what do you mean like you know how
like
base doesn't let you just drive on if
you're a civilian credential well if
he's the military he's driving around
everywhere yeah what if you're not
military though
oh are you talking about a civilian
crossing over to military that i have
never heard of i have nothing that's
like getting ignited that's what that's
what i was thinking about too because
like usually when i hear somebody's like
an honorary something it'd be like a
like an honorary kindred memory it's
like you're not a kindred but like we're
just honored that you can come in with
the crew me and joe like me and joe like
that yeah when doctors get like honorary
doctorates from like a random university
oh yeah yes exactly like hillary clinton
just got one yeah that i never heard of
civilian crossing over never but i've
heard of like someone that was
like a uh private first class and then
it became like a corporal i've heard you
guys know what rank james bond is and
the james bond and the royal navy i
thought they don't even exist mi6
doesn't talk about daniel craig talking
about daniel craig he's an honorary
military he just was made an honorary
commander in the british royal
though
[ __ ] he could do anything without being
in the military no he's not in the
military
james bond or just say daniel craig
though this is crazy true true dude that
[ __ ] might as well be a
commander can he just tell people like
hey private i'm a commander now and they
have to respect it because he has a
title yeah he's supposed to how come
this fool looks more legitimate
i know right yeah you actually like like
when you watch the good fellas saying
this guy looks like a little [ __ ] like
ray yoda and robert nero look way more
mafia than the guys that they're playing
even the guy yeah you know we watched
casino recently
and then the guy that uh robert de niro
plays lefty uh rosenthal he looks like a
he looks like a
like a really weak simp
yay dude it's crazy that movie sounds
like the ultimate diss by the way you
look like
weeks i mean de niro just looks like a
man man right but you know in the movie
casino
de diro's character is quite the sim
because like
because he's doing a deniro impression
here
he's doing a dinero impression
that's interesting that's not him is he
him yeah because his the girl that he
falls in love with constantly has a side
piece man
right so he yeah there's another picture
of him but
um
dude and i can say that i have whack
hair too
but yeah uh it's because
he was that the character was that so it
just doesn't look right with de niro
being that way because he's more
masculine he's way cooler like that
cooler yeah
that's [ __ ] crazy i've never heard of
a civilian crossing over into the
military like that i wonder how the uk
does do random [ __ ] like that right like
think about like uh knighting somebody
sir elton john yeah what is that about
what is what does it mean to be a knight
in i never saw elton john on a [ __ ]
horse jousting people yeah you know he
jokes people though but that i
understand more because they have a they
have a history of the king and queen
knighting people for centuries
you know like you can do something you
could save my daughter's life i knight
you here's a plot of land so it's like
part of their history well that's what
i'm saying maybe there's some sort of
like because of the uk specifically this
isn't necessarily like american military
we might be referencing right this is
like in the british naval honorary then
you know it's not that powerful
is a very also uk like yeah you know
that would be like that'd be like what's
up
or jack ryan or something like david
that's like can you name a canadian
general like without laughing
do they general maple do they have
honorary that's is he the first honorary
like military person no he's not but oh
okay it is sean connery it was before
probably but it is interesting that they
they made him a an honorary commander
because james bond is also a commander
so that's why they made him commander
and in fact it really just like you
enter
and you're what's called a mate then
you're a lieutenant then you're a
commander so it's not that high of a
right so this is really just fan service
yeah absolutely this is just press
publicity for the movie coming out we
hadn't had we should have had a solid
city for the navy
should have been an honorary do you want
to be a commander like james bond oh
yeah honorary mess cook steven seagal
all right
oh you know who recently had one of
these manny pacquiao did too really yeah
he was an honorary something this full
war is military uniform this fight like
six thousand ribbons and [ __ ] medals
i'm like basketball
oh my that's like some [ __ ] like
north korean dictator you just add
whatever the which he is now running for
president yeah yeah he's running for
president dude but usually it's like oh
you saved the motherfucker's life you
jumped on a grenade you know this was
just like went to the army surplus store
and like get me everything i might put
everything right here those are all the
people he beat up put me 12 stars
[Laughter]
are you all a fan of uh daniel craig's
james bond i love it he's my favorite
one he's so good [ __ ] love it casino
royale is so good that's a great movie
so good skyfall great movie yeah for me
it's my favorite one because it's the
most believable one yeah which one
christina wrote daniel craig yeah yeah
him as like james bond well slowly
they're amping up like his toys and
gadgets and all that stuff like the
style to be more original and he's
getting more bendies where he could jump
off a building but casino route was the
very very first like that you know and
they people hated on him for it by the
way did you guys see that documentary
jill hates him i like the one before
yeah cause jill thinks like
what she understands james bond to be is
like the suave smooth talking guy and
danielle craig is just too like too
rugged but in the books he's more rugged
apparently i've never read the [ __ ]
but also though did you really believe
pierce brosnan was doing never i never
believed him dude but he was hot as [ __ ]
dude
oh my god much of a puss with the dad
bud yeah but he is so [ __ ] hot he was
bro i don't know i don't know people say
sean connery was the hottest one i don't
get it no yeah but i understand it if
you were like born in the 60s yeah
that's those are the people that say
that at that time but i like that one
though i just rewatched the rock you
guys remember the rock yes what's up is
still hot yeah he's like an old man so
was nicholas cage at the time right he
really is too by the way that there's
like an internet thing i encourage
anyone to look it up but basically the
rock is almost like a lost james bond
movie because like he he's basically
sean connor is playing james bond in
that movie like if you think about it
the older james one that was captured
who went to jail not just yet but but
exactly so like just after doctor know
the idea is that he got captured and
that actually lines up with some of the
[ __ ] from the movies there's a great
reddit post about it that i read it was
like [ __ ] nuts is mind-blowing i i
love the rock it was cool to see like
great movies like both american
militaries like fighting each other
because you'll never see that yeah so
that concept of like you stand down no
you stand there no you stand there you
stand there i love that part yeah i love
that [ __ ] i will not be i would not
believe that order yeah yeah you [ __ ]
love that scene dude i feel like the
genre changed though like it's more
actiony yeah with with sean i mean uh
the sean connery stuff was more like
austin powery
yeah
that's true
remember there's like that one little
dude in there
the little guy you're talking about odd
job
he wasn't really little if you actually
it's funny because you remember it that
way because i thought he was just a
little person remember the game he was
like really small [ __ ] but in real life
the guy's a [ __ ] he's a [ __ ] he's
a big hawaiian dude yeah you know what's
interesting
no no no the other guy the there's an
actual little person in the one it's the
it's the one from the 60s oh really yeah
i don't remember okay i believe it but
mini-me was a parody of that guy oh
right from dr now or whatever yeah yeah
yeah yeah but i think back then it was
more like
more like mystery like espionage like
quirky character it's more of a spy and
sex it was its own genre very spy it
created the spy sex yeah but then with
the daniel craig it just feels like any
other action movie like the the mystique
or the the brand of 007 i feel like just
turned into an action movie like mission
impossible you guys don't think he's
slick though he's slick
you know
one of the recent ones um cube visits
him he just gives them a gun and like a
[ __ ] radio yeah yeah the watch radio
i kind of thought it was charming in its
own way because it's like more that
makes sense realistic instead of [ __ ]
pierce boston getting an invisible car
well like or like kingsman
the kingsman movies which is an ode to
the old spy styles which were a lot more
over thought yeah an umbrella that has
[ __ ] geo pro like
not just realistic right but maybe
somewhere in the middle colin first got
shot like 900 times and then he's alive
in the second movie i was like what the
[ __ ] i'm sick though i i enjoyed daniel
craig i love him yeah it's cool when it
comes out the water and [ __ ] he's all
sexy i'm like i'm like biting my lips
all the time dude in fact that was the
moment that everybody finally start
started believing in him as james bond
because like uh in this new uh apple tv
documentary that just came out about it
because i remember reading about how
people were giving him a lot of hate
people hated that he was blonde people
hated that he was like not as sexy and
and craig not bond he was kind of he was
kind of like ugly yeah right so people
were just hating on him yeah and then
the paparazzi apparently [ __ ] like
literally in that casino morale uh scene
where he comes out the water right
paparazzi apparently like stayed in the
sand hid dug and hunt hid in the sand
for like the night wow in order to be
able to get the shots of him coming out
the water but then when they got it and
he was all sexy as [ __ ] that's when
everybody's like all right i'm excited
for you he's in right so it's like super
superficial but at the same time like
well observed well before that i just
knew him because he was in the tomb
raider movie with angelina jolie yeah he
was and he's always a supporting role so
it didn't feel right to have him be like
the lead but he killed it i like that
one scene where uh in casino royale
where he was poisoned right and he
noticed yeah oh [ __ ] but then you like
i think that's where his acting chops
really kicked in where you see him try
to like keep everything under control
while not giving away that he's like
vulnerable now and he goes to the car
he's trying to put the [ __ ]
electrodes in but he's still trying to
keep it cool while [ __ ] dying yeah
yeah yeah same time then it cuts back to
like hq and they're like oh just put her
down
and you see him die but then finally get
it
she saves him she pushes yeah so it was
cool to like see him under extreme
duress still try to keep it cool and
like you're like okay that's that's dumb
and then he gets revived and then he's
like what's it up he's like you gotta
finish this [ __ ] casino game and he
shows back up at the table and they're
like the guy's like oh [ __ ] yeah yeah
that's the best it feels like [ __ ]
that's right
so good it was directed by um martin
campbell who also did goldeneye which is
like one of my favorite bomb movies of
all time gold knight is really good even
even the video game yeah they did a good
64. it's all blocky now
those two it was the first of the best
shooter that was the first first-person
shooter that was like one of the og ones
i think he turned to the corner like
that yeah dude so sick
i i got into james bond during roger
moore arab
roger
roger was great was he the original no
no it's not connor everybody connor no
no it goes oh there's something this one
before something no it goes connery and
then it goes um this guy named uh what
the [ __ ] the name
one he's a model and he did on her
majesty's secret service george lassenby
and then he
um
lost the job because he wanted too much
money or some [ __ ] and then they got
roger what's the one when when they went
to thailand
uh that's bangkok dangerous
they've been all over the place there's
the asia one yeah they're the own
they've been all over i'm just trying to
remember which one i don't know no the
old one the old old like the 70s one in
asia
yeah definitely more though okay
it's like octopussy and living that dog
was a hangover
there was no asian actually
i don't know could be any of them bro
love you long time
[Music]